There are many variations of using textures to modify the surface's parameters
in the lighting equation. Another way to vary the surface while calculating
illumination is to apply textures as light sources. We've seen how a skybox can
be made to surround a scene. An extremely clever technique is to have surfaces
reflect the skybox. This technique is called reflection mapping, or sometimes
environment mapping. The basic idea is to make one object surrounding the world
something that other objects can reflect. This is called the environment map.
The illumination process is a bit like ray tracing, where a ray is reflected
off a shiny surface and picks up color of any reflected objects. This
difference is that there is only one simple object to reflect, typically a cube
map. Unlike a skybox, the environment map is only used when a shiny surface
needs a reflected color. You can certainly also put a skybox in a scene using
the same cube map. This is commonly done in order to produce a convincing
effect. However, the environment map is a separate object that is part of the
shiny object's material description. That said, skyboxes and reflection maps
work using the same idea. You can think of a skybox as a physical object which
is what we usually do, or you can think of it as a texture function. What is
the color of the skybox in the direction the eye is looking? An environment map
is exactly the same only for reflected rays. What is the color of the
environment map in the reflected direction? How it works is this. We render a
fragment on a reflective surface such as a sphere. We compute the usual
elements as desired such as diffuse ambient and so on. For the environment map,
we also need the direction to the eye and the shading normal at the fragment.
These two vectors are used to compute the reflection direction which is then
used to find the texel on our environment map. This texel color can then be
blended in to the final color of the fragment. The color from the reflection
map makes the surface appear mirror like. The very simplest cube map to reflect
is one that's at infinity. Remember how a directional light came from a certain
direction but was considered infinitely far away? Directional lights are
inexpensive to use because their direction vector never changes for any
surface. Similarly if you define an environment map as being at infinity,
you're saying that no matter where I am in my virtual world, when I look a
certain direction I want to always get the same color back from my environment
map. To sum up, the reflection direction is computed for a reflective surface,
and this direction is then used to access the environment map. This algorithm
has limitations somewhat the reverse of the skybox. The reflected objects are
always seen as being infinitely far away. For example, say you have a
reflective sphere in a room represented by an environment map in a skybox. If
you move the sphere from the center of the room to near a wall, the reflection
of the wall will not look closer. That said, reflection mapping is an
inexpensive way to add convincing visual detail to a model. Our eyes are
usually not very good at reversing the process of reflection. We see something
reflected and our brains interpret the object we're viewing as being shiny. We
don't waste brainpower trying to figure out if the reflections are perfectly
correct, since in the real world they always are.